so what made you wanna being your wife
were you guys just total just [ __ ]
out of the gate or like what was the
whole deal there ya know my wife my wife
was your wife's a beautiful lady to
manage my spend time Rose are very sweet
she's great she's great
I started she didn't get a real short
haircut did she know okay good and
that's something that does in cuz a lot
of couples start to look the same as
they get older and if they're still
[ __ ] and they're not you got a that
to me is there something else is going
on no no it's like they're just trying
to make one person as hard as they can
I had sex with a girl a day that's grown
College you cut her all her hair got a
pixie haircut and we're having sex
and as we're [ __ ] I'm drunk right now
is her [ __ ] I went he's like [ __ ]
a dude oh yeah I was like what the [ __ ]
um I met LeeAnn and we dated for a
little bit I did want to put a label on
it and then she dumped me
mhm and then when she dumped me I fought
to get her back I made her a mix tape I
did everything what else do you do every
throw you mean honestly I was crying I
was crying or driving down there like do
you buy flowers no I'm [ __ ] crying
okay I made salt water with my eyes okay
I went to an a a meeting I did
everything I went to a meeting
dude I gotta say meeting in there like
and I'm with this guy I guess I
shouldn't say his name but huh he's like
he's like you should stand up and talk
and I was like I was just lost man I
wanted this chick back Wow what did you
say this is great cuz I go to a meeting
so what do you say if you so they go um
I love this was like alright I go I
don't know if I feel comfortable talking
I haven't really made any decisions
about what I'm doing in my life I'm just
trying to like get this chick back and
see if I have a problem because the
reason we broke up is I gotten drunk at
a dinner party and I just argued with
her friend and I wouldn't let it go and
so I could see that and so uh he goes
yeah I just talk I'm like okay I'm gonna
talk and part of me as a comic I'm like
yeah I gotta get up it's a little little
stage time as bad guy in front of me I
love it there I go to go to stand up
right and then the guy in front of me
stands up he goes do you mind if I go
and I was like oh sorry
yeah go ahead he stands up he goes hi my
name's Dave or whatever yeah I'm an
alcoholic and everyone's like hi Dave
he's like it's been a rough day
who this morning my landlord came over
and I sucked his dick and then I lit his
car on fire oh my god and I was like I
can't follow that yeah I was like I let
somebody else go I can't go right after
that I'm gonna [ __ ] eat a bullet up
next guy you're like this is the
crystally of a meeting so I didn't say
anything he can get up and I left and I
was like I was like I don't know if
that's for me and then and then like the
next day I went on a jog down outpost I
came running down outpost on to Franklin
I live right over by Hollywood Island
and I and I was I was like I don't know
what for me you were out here when you
met your lady oh yeah yeah yeah and I
was like I don't know what's wrong with
me I feel like I don't I was like I
really don't feel like I have a drinking
problem I really don't feel like by
going need to stay sober for a while get
my head straight if I'm gonna be single
I need to figure out what I'm doing with
my life
and I had this a moment that I spoke to
God gods and then God said if you want
her back he's just got a promise that
she's the one and you won't [ __ ] it up I
swear to God I spoke to God no idea and
I was like I go I'll never [ __ ] this up
just give her to me and I will never
[ __ ] it up I'll marry her and this will
be my chick this is the one for me he's
like I remember him saying in my head to
me hmm
remember what you just said I got home
and she was in my bedroom on my bed and
she was in a sundress and she goes I
think we need to figure out how to was
she doing in there she had just gone to
church she'd gone to a church down in
Compton cuz she's Baptist and she
couldn't mine when I'm here and she'd
gone to a church in Compton and and in
church someone had said to her in her
head you need to get this guy this guy's
a good guy he needs a second chance
Wow and so then we just we hung out we
had a great time didn't party for like
six months it didn't drink for like six
months and then one day we're in Italy
it's New Years Eve and it's snowing on
Venice it just starts snowing I'd [ __ ]
you there that sounds beautiful
and I said I said to her I said I gotta
be honest with you this is what I want a
drink is like it's snowing we're in same
you drank for six months six months I
didn't drink and I didn't have a like
that's the other problem is I don't have
a problem quitting drinking like I
almost have a problem starting up again
right it's so like I go I don't I just
feel like I I want a drink
she goes honey I don't think of a
drinker problem I have a drink Wow we
had a cup we had a but we split a bottle
of wine went out in the snow in st.
marks it was an
it was [ __ ] empty was like the day
after near XIV pound is shut down and it
was [ __ ] gorgeous st. Mark's Saint
Mark's is a big square in Venice it's
like just huge and it was just starting
to snow it was like perfect snow
everywhere I was [ __ ] great and so
yeah I've been with her ever since well
thanks for watching that video right
there that was a beautiful little
segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe subscribe